[Music]
tom brady and gisele boonshin reportedly
hitting a rough patch in their marriage
you know she really committed so much of
her time to make sure everything was so
stable at home so i could go live my
dream according to multiple reports the
a-list couple's problem started when tom
returned to the nfl less than two months
after announcing his retirement did you
just need a vacation is that what
brought you back there was a little more
than that uh but at the same time i took
some time away which is always important
it's tough to make a decision right at
the end of the season it's a big
commitment to make for football
and it's not something you just can
decide i needed time and i just figured
i'm going to go at it again and see what
we can accomplish so the reports claim
gisele was thrilled when tom first
decided to retire followed by her
disappointment when that turned out to
be short-lived it gets harder and harder
as you get older because you do take on
a lot more in your life yeah the rumor
mill's gone into overtime with tom and
gisele
last month tom made headlines after
missing practices kicking off
speculation there was trouble in
paradise
tom has been excused today he's going to
deal with some personal things this is
something we talked about before
training camp started tom kept his
explanation pretty vague when asked
about the time off
it's all personal you know everyone's
got different situations they're dealing
with so we all have really unique
challenges to our life and
uh
you know we're
i'm 45 years old man there's a lot going
on so
you know you just got to try to figure
out light the best you can and it's a
continuous process so and i think
prioritization i think has been the key
for me as i've gotten older you know tom
and giselle married in 2009.
she's amazing at her job she's one of
the she is the goat
and she's an amazing uh model mother
environmentalist
uh director producer look at all the
things she did she is amazing they share
two children together twelve-year-old
son benjamin and nine-year-old daughter
vivian they're just the biggest blessing
in my life i'm sure all the parents out
there
and
yeah not a day goes by where you don't
laugh and smile at something that they
do
and just a few months ago tom admitted
that playing football takes a toll on
his family life i want to try to spend
my time with when i'm focused on my job
my job when i'm focused with my family
my family and i look back at my parents
and my dad mom did the same thing for me
so
i think what i was very emotional about
is i do feel maybe some guilt that i
haven't been able to do that in the same
way for my kids and i feel like i'm so
driven to succeed in football and that's
taken me away from
other important priorities which are my
kids my wife and she's really held it
down for our family
you